une immense victoire de la droite c'est
ce que revendique benyamin nétanyahou
aux élections législatives le likoud son
parti aurait récolté de 31 à 33 des
sièges sur 120 selon les premières
estimations ce dont s'est félicité le
premier ministre
ce soir c'est un accomplissement
incroyable
nous avons fait du likoud le plus grand
parti d'israël avec une marge
confortable
l'état a besoin d'un gouvernement stable
pas d'un gouvernement de bric et de broc
fondée sur des disqualifications
personnel et sur des ambitions un
gouvernement stable pour l'état
israélien c'est ce que la période exige
c'est ce que les défis qui se présentent
à nous et exige nous ne devons en aucun
cas entraîner israël vers de nouvelles
élections
vers des cinquièmes législatives nous
devons former un gouvernement stable dès
à présent sur la team même show la
miotte sebha octobre mais les résultats
examiné au cours de la nuit place le
bloc de netanyahou et celui de son rival
centriste
yaïr lapid au coude à coude les deux
hommes obtiendrait une cinquantaine de
sièges chacun la partie n'est donc pas
complètement gagné pour le premier
ministre qui doit rassembler
suffisamment de soutien pour obtenir la
majorité et former un gouvernement
il pourrait compter sur des alliances
religieuses mais aussi sur la droite
radicale et le parti de naftali bennett
qui laisse planer le doute sur une
éventuelle coalition avec l'actuel
premier ministre
peu importe le gouvernement qui sera
formé je suis déterminé à faire
progresser les valeurs de la droite mais
un vrai droitiste qui n'est pas dans la
confrontation mais dans l'union je
n'agirais qu'en fonction d'un seul
principe directeur ce qui est bon pour
israël et pour l'ensemble de ses
citoyens
machtal l'éclat des nattes et son
symbole de l'opposition cayir lapide qui
a mené une campagne anti netanyahu
continue de faire front dans cette
élection
espérant chasser le premier ministre du
pouvoir je pense que nous avons une
bonne raison d'être fier de la façon
dont nous nous sommes investis et des
résultats que nous avons obtenus pour le
moment netanyahu ne dispose pas de 61
sièges mais le bloc du changement lui
les à une position que tient également
la liste unifiée qui regroupe le parti
d'extrême gauche et trois formations
arabe et qui dénonce un programme
raciste et extrémiste capitaliste de la
droite en deux ans israël a connu quatre
élections et la lassitude électorale se
fait ressentir avec un taux de
participation de quelque 67%
la commotion a prévu de publier les
résultats officiels
ce vendredi avant la pâque juive